just before we get started with today's video
thank you to keeps for sponsoring it did you know
that two out of every three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35. you're soon gonna be joining
the club guys yes for me it was more like 25
but you know who's counting i wish keeps have been
around when i was younger because advancements in
science meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and help you
keep the hair that you have look it's too late
for me my hair's not coming back but you didn't
have to be like me you could stop your hair loss
early thanks to keep keeps offers generic versions
of the only two fda approved drugs for treating
hair loss so you might have tried them before
but you've never tried them at a price this
low yes if you were thinking oh my god simon
this is a medicine thing it's gonna be super
expensive well no with keeps it just starts at 10
a month how does it work well you don't have
to visit a doctor's office just you schedule
a quick online consult and then a little bit
later discrete package arrives at your door
you can use it in the privacy of your own home
so if you're noticing that you're losing your
hair like it's not going to fix itself i promise
you that do something about it for a limited time
go to keeps.com forward slash biographics
or click the link in the description below
and you will receive 50 of your
first order and now today's video
on january the 10th 49 bc julius caesar did
something that changed the course of history he
ignored orders from the roman senate to disband
his armies and instead he crossed the rubicon
river into italy something considered treason
a civil war erupted that ultimately led to the
demise of the republic and the rise of the roman
empire thus solidifying julius caesar's place
as the most famous and influential roman of
all time you're probably familiar with that
story but you might not know that 40 years
earlier somebody else did the same thing
a man named sulla feeling betrayed by the
machinations of his political opponents and
benefiting from the unwavering support of his
troops sulla marched into rome and chased away
his rivals then a few years later he did
the same thing again except that this time
his enemies were ready for him leading
to the first civil war in roman history
and causing sulla to become the first man to
seize power from the roman republic by force
lucius cornelius sulla was born in 138 bc in
patioli near naples today known as posuoli
as his name might suggest he was part of one of
the oldest patrician houses in rome jen's cornelia
however in sulla's time that name didn't carry
much weight anymore the family had lost most of
its wealth and respect following the actions of
one of its ancestors publius cornelius ruffanus
plutarch has given us the most detailed account of
sulla's life and he said that ruffanus disgraced
himself while serving as consul around 300 bc
although his actions weren't exactly front-page
scandal material apparently all he did was amass
more than his allotted share of silver for this
rufunus was expelled from the senate and his
family subsequently lost a lot of its wealth
and power it's not like they were poor not by a
long shot but plutarch mentions that sulla when
he was young lived in cheap lodgings that were
only mildly better than those of a freedmen aka
a commoner in his youth sulla lived by the study
hard play-hard mantra he was fond of wine and
women and often engaged in revelry in the company
of actors and musicians a practice he continued
all his life for when sulla was once at a table he
underwent a complete change as soon as he betook
himself to good fellowship and drinking so that
comic singers and dancers found him anything but
ferocious it was this laxity which produced in him
a diseased propensity to amorous indulgence and an
unrestrained voluptuousness from which he did not
refrain even in his old age in order to improve
his financial situations was not above serving as
a boy toy in his early twenties he received two
legacies that he used to enter politics the first
was from his stepmother but the other was from a
rich widow named nicopolis who was so impressed
with the young man's fortitude that she named
sulla as her heir his first notable position was
that of a questor during the consulship of the man
who would eventually become his arch-nemesis gaius
marius in 112 bc roma declared war on the kingdom
of namidia in north africa because they'd
supported hannibal during the punic wars
this conflict became known as the jagerstein war
named after the king of numeria jagertha it didn't
turn out to be the walk in the park that rome
had hoped for four consoles fought namidia and
they all came back defeated and humiliated
until gaius marius took command in 107 bc
at first it seemed like marius was destined to
meet the same fate if not for the devious actions
of his new questa in order to get to jagatha sulla
appealed to his ally king barkus of mauritania
who agreed to betray the namidian ruler in
exchange for the western half of his kingdom
even so this still was a massive risk for sulla
who stepped right into the lion's den of bacchus's
camp escorted only by a handful of soldiers
the trap that he laid for jugartha could have
just as easily been his own undoing if bacchus
decided that he preferred the favor of numidia
over that of rome but the mauritanian king
delivered on the goods jagertha and a small
retinue unsuspectingly entered the mauritanian
camp his soldiers were cut down immediately
while the numidian king was brought to rome
in chains where he died in prison in 104 bc
as we all know rome was never really the live
and let live kind of place while it was engaged
in the jigarcian war it also took part in another
conflict against another confederation of germanic
tribes led by the simbri that migrated into
roman controlled territory the cimbrian war
as it was called saw rome suffer several losses in
its early stages including the humiliating battle
of orozio which gave the roman republic its worst
defeat since hannibal over a hundred years prior
once again gaius marius was the one tasked with
vanquishing rome's enemies basically he was given
carp lost by the senate to do whatever he wanted
as long as he stopped the germanic tribes from
marching into rome a danger which had become a
very real possibility given how things were going
marius was fortunate that for whatever reason the
cymbrians did not press their advantage if they
would have invadedly immediately following their
victory at arucio then they would have almost
certainly been able to sack the eternal city
despite the brewing discord between gas marius
and sulla the former recognized the talent of the
latter which is why marius continued to recruit
sulla into his service even promoting him to a leg
ace and giving him command of his own legion for
his part sulla showed off his value first when
he defeated the textus aegis and captured their
chieftain corpulus and then when he persuaded the
marsey tribe to leave the germanic confederation
and ally itself with rome things seemed to
be going well but they took a turn in 102 bc
guys marius had just received the consulship for
the fourth time but instead of serving under him
solo requested to be transferred to the
other consul quintus letatius catalyst
plutarch described catalyst as a worthy man but
too sluggish for arduous contests and maybe this
is exactly what sulu was looking for a lazy boss
who had passed down their responsibilities to
him cause marius was too ambitious for this but
catalyst entrusted solo with important enterprises
thus enabling him to achieve power and glory
in battle when sula was in charge of provisions
he not only made sure his own soldiers lived in
plenty but sent the extra rations to marius as men
with a cheeky wink and a nod a pure owl torns that
forewarned the strife and violence yet to come
after rome won the cimbrian war ziller had
earned enough personal fame that he could
pursue a successful political career in 97 bc he
was made praetor urbanus in rome and later served
as pro-prater in the province of celesia while
their sula had to travel to nearby cappadocia
to help restore king ariel barzones to the throne
he had been overthrown by mithridates the sixth
king of pontus who wanted to install one of his
own sons on the throne it is unlikely that rome
actually cared about arya barzan's their main
concern was to limit the influence of mithridates
whose power had grown to the point that he had
become a serious threat but more on that later but
now sulla did as asked restored arya barzanese
to the throne of cappadocia without too much
hassle and he returned to roman 93 bc just in
time to be impeached for bribery by a man named
sensarinus fortunately for him this sensoriness
never appeared at the trial for whatever reason
so the whole thing was dropped until it was back
on track to leading rome and yet another war
when sulla arrived in rome he discovered mounting
tensions between the romans and the other groups
of confederates who lived in italy collectively
known as saki primarily led by the marcy and the
sam knight they didn't want to be regarded as
second class citizen anymore they wanted roman
citizenship and equal rights and unsurprisingly
rome didn't want to give them this and thus the
social began in 93 bc sula primarily
fought against the sam knights and the
penny in southern italy he successfully besieged
the cities of pompei and herculaneum before
capturing the main settlement of the herpini
a killarney his greatest triumph was outside
the city of nola where he overwhelmed an army
of twenty thousand pompeians including their
general cluntius he annihilated them with a
show of unbridled and remorseless force like
mount vesuvius itself the war ended in 87 bc with
another roman victory and sulla was named consul
for the first time in 88 bc at the age of 50.
for his actions sulla was awarded the grass crown
which although it didn't sound too impressive was
actually the highest military distinction of the
roman republic clinty the elder described what
made this crown so special but as for the crown
of grass it was never conferred except at a crisis
of extreme desperation never voted except by the
acclamation of the whole army and never to anyone
but to him who had been its preserver other crowns
were awarded by the generals to the soldiers
this alone by the soldiers and to the general
before the social war was even over the roman
republic was already embroiled in another conflict
in asia remember mithridates king of pontus who
tried to take over cappadocia well he did it
again in the summer of 89 bc and this time he was
successful while he was there he also conquered
the neighboring kingdom of bithynia which was a
client state of rome and in 88 bc he carried out
the asiatic vespers a genocide of all romans
and other latin-speaking groups estimates of
casualties range between 80 and 150 000 people
and once he had done this war became inevitable
the first mithridatic war began in 89 bc the
commission to lead the troops was a dream job
for every general in rome because it promised
to be rich in plunder and prestige as consul and
the premier military leader of that time
the honor went to sulla to the chagrin of
gaius marius who still coveted the
position even though he was almost
70 years old by that point fortunately for him
sula's rise brought him plenty of other enemies
all marius had to do was conspire with one
of them tribune publius sulpicious rufus
to strip sulla of the command and grant him to
himself when word of the betrayal reached sully
he decided he wasn't going to just lie down and
take it the strife between him and marius had
been brewing for a long time and now it was time
to act sullives let the support of his men roughly
thirty thousand soldiers so he did something
unprecedented he marched on rome stiller first
captured the esquiline gate and as he and his army
were making their way through the streets of rome
they were pelted with rocks by the unarmed masses
who had taken refuge on the roofs of their homes
tulla's response was extreme as he ordered his
men to begin setting fire to the houses of those
who attacked them by this point guys marius knew
he was in deep deep trouble he made a last-ditch
attempt to secure protection by asking the slaves
and gladiators to take up arms on his behalf but
shockingly they refused marius quickly fled the
city with his tail tucked between his legs while
his co-conspirator sulpicius was betrayed and
killed by one of his servants now that sulla
was in charge he convened the senate and placed
a death sentence on gaius marius and a few of
his close supporters as you might expect zilla's
actions brought him the enmity of the senate and
the steps he took to try and win them back
had little success to show that the republic
was still free he allowed one of his political
opponents lucius sinner to become consul which
turned out to be a foolish move afterward
sulla concerned himself again with the war
against mithridates unsurprisingly he was
confirmed as the commander once more and he
made plans to travel to asia as soon as sulla was
out of italy lucius sinner began conspiring with
gaius marius who had retreated to north africa
in 87 bc marius returned from exile with an army
and charged rome he basically repeated sulla's
playbook but wanted to show everyone that he
could be much much worse what followed were
five days of chaos death and violence as he
and sinner decapitated many of sula's supporters
and displayed their heads on the rost trap the
elevated platforms which faced the senate house as
a nice little reminder of what happened to those
who went against them eventually they stopped
making distinctions between friend and foe and
started killing people whose property they coveted
in 86 bc marius and sinha put themselves forward
as candidates for consulship and surprise surprise
they were both elected unfortunately we never got
an ultimate battle between the two fierce rivals
because just two weeks after becoming consul gaius
marius died of natural causes leaving his position
to another of synod allies lucius valerius flaccus
while this mayhem was going on in rome solar
focused on his war against mithridates and
started with his greek allies at this point in
history the greeks had only been under roman
hegemony for a few decades so many of them jumped
at the opportunity when mithridates came along
and offered to help them escape the roman yoke
of oppression however when sulla showed up with
his legions armed to the teeth and ready for war
they realized that life under roman rule might not
be so bad after all so they switched sides again
and sent ambassadors to ask sula for forgiveness
one notable exception was aristian the tyrant king
of athens who pined for the city's glory days and
remained allied with mithridates in the hopes
that athens might again flourish as the beacon
of culture of the greek world thus the city-state
became sulla's first target as he laid siege not
only on athens but also on the nearby port city
of piraeus this would stop food shipments from
getting to athens it was ruthless but effective
soon enough the city was a wretched site to behold
struck by famine deaths even cannibalism and
by early spring 86 bc athens and aristian were
executed by this point some of sewell's supporters
who managed to escape the carnage back in rome had
begun arriving at his camp so stillen knew
that the marius in a faction had taken over and
declared him an enemy of the state but as we
said gaius marius was already dead by then and
he would soon be joined by his replacement
consul lucious valerius flaccus flaccus had
been given the task of dealing with both sulla and
mithridates and considering that he only had two
legions this was somewhat optimistic but flakus
never even made it to the battlefield because he
was betrayed by one of his officers a man named
flavius fimbria who clearly thought that he was
better suited for the job in nicomedia fimbria
assassinated flaccus by cutting off his head and
throwing it into the sea then he declared himself
the new commander and went to fight mithridates
fimbria was more successful than expected
against the king of pontus but then something
happened which he'd not anticipated as his two
enemies banded together against him mithradartis
realized that the war was lost so he made peace
with sulla he agreed to renounce bithynia and
cappadocia pay sulla 2000 talents and give him
70 ships and in exchange sula would confirm
mithridates as the rightful ruler of his other
dominions and get him recognized as an ally of
rome and then of course there was the matter of
dealing with fimbria which did not prove difficult
at all sulla's much larger army surrounded
the enemy camp at which point fimbria's men
mutinied and switched sides fimbria fled to
pergamon where he entered the temple of asclepius
and committed suicide becoming sulla's third
roman enemy to die without actually fighting him
and he wouldn't be the last at this rate the
whole matter would have probably been settled
itself if sulla simply waited long enough but
instead he intended to march on rome again
back in rome word arrived that flaccus
had been less than stellar in his mission
and lucius sinner realized that sula would now be
returning to italy to look for a fight besides him
other leading members of his faction were a man
named cabo who basically replaced flakus and
the son of gaius marius gaius marius the younger
meanwhile silla also had some strong support since
sinner and gaius marius had made plenty of enemies
during their spree of assassinations exiles and
confiscations people you might remember such as
pompeii and marcus crassus had an axe to grind
with them so they raised armies in support of
sula the war began with a triumphal before he even
reached italy in 84 bc lucius sinner was killed
by his own men most likely following a mutiny this
left carbo and gas marius the younger in charge as
well as two newly elected consuls gas nubanus and
scepio asiaticus in 83 bc solar landed in southern
italy his first battle took place near capua
against norbhanus and it was a decisive victory
he then encountered the other console scepio with
his army but the two sides never came to blows
scepio's troops consisted mainly of inexperienced
soldiers who were not eager to fight still as
veterans many of them deserted others switched
sides and scepio had no choice but to surrender
and enter talks with his enemy for his part sulla
tried to be diplomatic and send skibio back with
messages for the senate and his strategy seemed
to pay off more and more men not just soldiers but
also statesmen and generals were siding with sulla
the third major encounter of the war occurred in
april 82 bc when sulla took on gaius marius the
younger and his main force it was another victory
priscilla who forced marius to retreat and take
refuge in the fortress city of preenesta zuller
left one of his generals to lay siege on marius
and he continued his way towards rome meanwhile
he had received good news from his allies who had
bested the enemy and other parts of italy pompeii
in particular was responsible for giving carbo a
crushing defeat at clusium which resulted in 20
000 casualties and most of the survivors taking
their ball and going home the decisive battle was
fought in early november 82 bc outside the walls
of rome by this point none of the leaders of the
marius sinner faction were even involved anymore
and their army consisted mostly of other italian
people such as sam knights and lukanians even so
the battle of the colin gate as it was called
almost ended in a shocking defeat for sulla it was
the actions of marcus crassus that won the day as
he completely routed the enemy on the right wing
while sulla was struggling to keep control on the
left with the civil war one tiller was appointed
dictator by the senate he showed little mercy
to his enemies as he executed or banished those
who opposed him and confiscated their properties
cabo norbanas marius the younger all died in 82
bc while scepio asiaticus was banished whilst was
unforgiving to his foes he also showed himself to
be very grateful to his friends men like pompei
and marcus crassus had their careers jump started
following their participation in the war as they
all became fabulously rich and powerful once the
rewards and punishments have been doled out tiller
gave himself immunity for all of his past actions
and served as consul in atbc the following year
once his consulship had ended sulla willingly
renounced his power giving an impassioned
speech in the forum to explain his actions
and how he didn't seek tyranny but it was thrust
upon him apparently it was convincing enough that
even statesmen such as cicero or historians like
plutarch and appian who despised sulla for his
actions still grudgingly had to admit a certain
admiration for him in 79 bc sula retired to his
villa in naples where he wrote his memoirs and
once again spent his days in the company of actors
and musicians he died the following year age 60
and was given a public funeral with honors back
in rome his tomb was placed in the campus martius
which proudly displayed sulla's motto in life no
better friend no worse enemy so i really hope you
found this video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching you